it's time for the first post-election
hatred mail I'll remind you about hatred
mail just in case you've forgotten it's
like a mandatory transvaginal ultrasound
for your mind patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America because freedom yeah I told you
last week that we had our last
pre-election election-related hatred
males we are now moving into policy
you'll see what I mean take a listen to
this David Pakman is gay
dumbass David and his liberal love of
open borders David Pakman is a so stupid
he makes me cringe we do have to hand it
to fudge Pakman here not many low
testosterone homosexual man China's are
capable of launching their own YouTube
pac-man auditioning for Hilary's groom
of the stool parents must be so proud
hey talking gay guy in the video you
just told one huge lie you are
brainwashing jump well listen no open
borders no open borders now under
president elect Donald Trump the wall
were getting them out the criminal
illegals as he talks about now we have
to ignore in that of course that Melania
Trump was one of those people who came
to the u.s. not authorized to work here
and she was working but she's a
Slovenian model not exactly a you know
the farm worker that is really really a
danger to anybody as Donald Trump would
have you say have you believe so hey
we'll see what happens we'll see if you
like what it is Donald Trump does with
that that that Mexican border I predict
it will be almost indistinguishable from
what we've seen under President Obama
which is way more deportations than we
saw under george w bush